if you're wondering why you should care
about a random German Vanishing 110
years ago when he disappeared from the
decks of the SS Dresden in 1913 Rudolph
diesel was one of the most famous
inventors alive but here's the strange
part to this day more than a century
later nobody really knows what happened
to him some people believe he fell
overboard in a tragic accident others
think he willingly jumped but still
others point to tantalizing evidence
that Rudolph diesel inventor of the
engine that quite literally changed the
world was murdered and that his killer
Got Away scottf Frey after pulling off
the perfect crime